I'm here at Google cloudex 2023 with ram
beer machine learning engineer at Google
who's been working with Uber the past
number of years so we are speaking on
some of the best practices which we have
learned with Uber really test driving
our generative AI models has been really
interesting we have been working with
them for the past 6 months they have uh
summarization use cases they have chat
use cases so super exciting we'll be
publishing some results uh looking
forward to everybody joining us whether
it's here in person or online after the
fact make sure you go check out ramer's
talk with Uber on how they're utilizing
machine learning Google Cloud